Scare the crap out of people this Halloween...
...by sporting some very realistic fake blood.
You will need a bottle of light corn syrup...
...and red, blue and yellow food coloring.
Optional: cough syrup and chicken livers.
Step one: Pour 16 ounces of light corn syrup into a bowl.
Step two: Add one tablespoon of red food coloring.
Step three: Mix thoroughly.
You can substitute clear cough syrup for the corn syrup.
Step four: To darken the blood,....
...mix in one drop of blue and yellow food coloring.
Need some guts to take the gore level over the top?
Mix in some chicken livers.
Step five: Smear it on your hands and let the bloodbath begin.
You're deranged.
You're a zombie.
You're a psycho killer on the loose.
And if you're not careful,...
...you're going to stain something with that red dye.
Did you know?
Hemophobia is the abnormal fear of blood.